-Welcome back.
-Thank you.
-Oh, I love that
little lapel pin.
-Thank you. It's a mushroom.
-I love it. I get it.
I get it --
-Because --
-No, no, I understand.
-No, because --
-No, no, no. I understand.
Don't explain.
-Because --
-No, no, no.
You like mushrooms.
-Yeah.
-That's right. Yeah.
Last time you were here,
we had the best time.
I appreciate
you coming to the show.
And you were very nervous
and excited
because your wife, Katherine,
was very pregnant
and was about to have a baby.
-That's right.
-And you had your phone out.
-Just in case.
-You go, "Just in case
anything goes down
just during this interview."
And...?
-We had a deal
that if she was born
while I was on the show
that I would name her Jimmy.
-Questlove?
[ Drum roll]
-She's named Eloise
'cause she was not born...
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Wow.
Beautiful. No, no, Beautiful.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-Bohm-bohm! Boo, Eloise!
-No, no, no!
-One day you'll see this,
and you'll know that I wish
your name was Jimmy...
-No, we love you.
-...not Eloise!
-Eloise.
Wait. That's beautiful.
-Isn't that beautiful? Yeah.
-You are now
the father of three.
Does that ever sink in, bud?
-Wow.
-This is -- You're a dad.
-Whew!
-Yeah. I mean...
-Yeah. Thank you.
-You're a fun dad.
-I love it, man. Yeah, I have --
-You have a 10...
-I got a 10-year-old,
2 1/2, and 10 months.
-Ooh!
The 10-year-old is my son Jack.
And then Lyla...
-Oh, yeah. Lyla.
How's Lyla doing?
-Oh, my gosh. She's --
She's the best. She's so girly.
She's so cute.
She loves dresses and bows
and all of the princessy stuff.
Pink is her favorite color.
And she loves to chat.
She's a real chatterbox.
She'll talk --
She was talking to
my sister on FaceTime,
and then my sister
later said, she goes,
"Lyla is like the
personification of a Mad Lib
'cause she knows
all these words,
but she doesn't quite know
how to really use them."
So she'll -- The other day,
she said, "Daddy, Daddy.
I'm going to Palm Beach
in two minutes!"
I said, "You are?"
She said, "Yes.
I'm going with Santa Claus.
We are going to bring
all of the sand."
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I was like,
"That's exactly a Mad Lib."
-Give me a noun. Give me a noun.
-Give me an adjective.
-Yeah. And how's Grandpa?
Arnold Schwarzenegger
is your grandpa.
-Yeah.
-He goes by "Opa."
-Oh.
-You know, he's Austrian.
German. "Opa" is "grandfather"
in German.
So he goes by "Opa."
-[As Arnold]
Did he have a cigar?
-Oh. [ Laughs ]
-Did you have a cigar
with him?
-Yes. Yes.
-Yes. You had the cigar?
-Yeah.
-[Normal] He loves his cigar.
-He loves his cigar.
-He came on the show.
He taught me
how to smoke a cigar.
-Yeah, he kind of
taught me, too.
I mean, there's nothing manlier
than Arnold Schwarzenegger
smoking a cigar.
-Yes.
-And when you're part of,
you know, bringing
his granddaughter
into the world,
he comes and he brings you
a cigar and he's like,
"Let's go out and smoke these."
And I was like, "Okay,"
but I have asthma,
so I don't like cigars.
And I was like,
"You got it, Arnold?
And Katherine's like,
"What are you doing?"
I was like, "I'm fine.
I'm gonna be okay."
And so I go and I smoke
the cigar and I'm like,
"This is good.
[ Coughs ] Hmm.
Oh, yeah. Cohiba? Nice."
And then woke up the next day.
Massive lung infection.
But -- Worth it.
-You always have to --
If Arnold says,
"Let's smoke a cigar..."
-You go, "Okay."
-Let's do it. Yeah.
You go, "Yeah."
-There's peer pressure,
and then there's...
-Arnold Schwarzenegger.
-...Arnold Schwarzenegger
pressure.
No, you do whatever --
He came on.
I said I want to understand it
and how to do it and everything,
because I smoked
a couple of cigars.
I don't know when.
And I'm like --
You bite the end off
and then you, like,
lick the side.
-He goes by,
"You don't bite and the lick.
What are you talking about?
You don't lick the cigar!
You don't lick it and bite it!"
So I go -- I think I did.
He's like, "No!"
He goes, "Next time
I'm in town, I'll teach you.
I'll take you to a cigar bar,
and I'll teach you how."
I go --
And he's a man of his word.
Called me on the phone.
-No.
-Said, "Jimmy, it's Arnold.
I'm going to a cigar bar."
And I was with --
I was with Drew Barrymore
and my wife, and I go,
"Do you guys want to go
to a cigar bar
with Arnold Schwarzenegger?"
They're like, "Let's do it."
We showed up,
and we all smoked cigars.
-Come on.
-It was the best.
Love that dude.
Congrats, Opa. Opa?
-Opa Arnold.
-Congratulations, Opa.
-Stogies.
-Congrats to you and Katherine.
-Thanks, man. Thank you.
Yeah, we're blessed.
We feel very blessed.
-Good, nice parents.
I want to talk "Super Mario
Bros." because that is --
That's the jam. I'm excited
about this Wednesday.
-Let's go.
-I'm excited.
-Go see it.
-You're Mario.
-I'm Mario.
I'm the voice of Mario.
-So what happens when
you get the phone call
and they're like,
"Hey, would you like
to be this iconic..."
-I'm like, "Pfft. No."
-Exactly.
-I was like,
"Oh, my God! Really?!"
Yeah, I mean,
you get that call.
And it's just really exciting
because,
I mean, if you think about it,
all the IP that's out there,
anything that has reach,
it's already been remade.
It's already been turned
into a TV show or a movie.
And for some reason.
the Super Mario Bros.
hasn't been a movie
for almost 30 years.
And it's because I think
the folks at Nintendo
just didn't want to give
anybody the permission
to make the movie,
and so finally they made...
-Oh, Illumination is --
-Illumination, you know --
"Despicable Me."
"Secret Life of Pets."
"Minions." Brilliant.
-"Minions." Incredible studio.
And so they partnered up
and they decided that they were
going to make this movie.
And so when something
like that comes around,
it's just like --
you're so blessed,
so honored to do it,
I mean, for me...
-It's fantastic.
It's gonna crush, buddy.
And, you know,
I was thinking about you
because I was watching it,
and there's a lot of action.
There's a lot of action
in this movie.
And I could just
kind of hear you --
a lot of grunting by you.
-Yes.
-Going like -- [ Grunting ]
And I go -- I was like --
"Oh, maybe Chris will bring
footage," of you doing
those grunts
when you come on the show.
I just want to see you
in the sound booth going like...
[ Both grunting ]
-Well, you know, here's
an interesting thing
about that, actually.
Usually the effort sounds you do
at the end of the session.
You probably do like
one or two sessions a month
over the course
of a couple years
to voice one of these movies.
And at the end, because
the efforts and the grunts
and the screaming, that really
takes it out of your voice,
they save that for the end.
But here's an interesting
little tidbit.
In a -- What makes
physical comedy work
in like a "Tom and Jerry"
or a "Super Mario Bros."
is when a character falls
a long way and hits,
they don't die, right?
If they died, it would --
If Tom and Jerry --
If, like, Road Runner --
If, like, the anvil
hit his head
and there's freaking brains
everywhere...
-No, no, no, no, no.
That'd be terrible.
-Be like, "Oh, my God!"
That'd be bad, right?
-Terrible idea. Terrible.
-So in order to let kids know
that the character's not dead...
-Yes.
-...you have to do an,
"I'm okay, I'm alive" sigh.
"I'm hurt, not injured"
sigh.
So it's like this.
You're like, "Aaaaaah!"
Unh!
Uhh...
-Yeah!
[ Applause ]
-Without that...
-It just goes, hey,
it's a joke, everybody.
-Kids will be like,
"Mario is dead!
Mario fell to his death, Dad!"
-That's so funny.
It's so well-done.
It's such a great cast.
Everyone's so talented and good.
A lot of fun people.
How do we set up the movie
with "Super Mario Bros."?
-There's a -- There's a clip?
-Yeah.
-You don't have to show it.
It's fine.
-No, we're definitely
showing the clip.
But if you want to set it up,
they're in Brooklyn.
-Oh, this is the --
I don't know what the clip is.
What's the clip?
It's from this movie called
"The Super Mario Bros."
And I'm in it.
-No, but the movie.
What is the movie about?
Not the clip.
The movie is about...
-It's about the
Super Mario Brothers.
[ Laughter ]
Am I not doing --
I'm gonna get fired.
-No! This is --
They're plumbers.
-They're plumbers.
-Right?
-There are turtles.
You know, they run around.
It sounds crazy,
but they smash their head
against things...
-Yes, yes, yes.
-...to get coins.
-And they go through a pipe and
they end up in a weird world.
-There's a princess.
-Seth Rogen plays...
-Donkey Kong.
-Yeah.
I want to show everyone a clip.
-You're gonna love it.
-Chris Pratt,
Keegan-Michael Key in
"The Super Mario Bros. Movie."
Take a look.
-Let's go.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Do not touch that mushroom!
-Aah!
-You'll die!
-Ah!
-Oh, I'm sorry.
That one's perfectly fine.
-It's a little mushroom man!
A little mushroom man
talking to me!
-Pleased to meet ya.
I'm Toad.
-Uh, Mario.
♪♪
So this is -- this is --
this is not a dream?
Aah!
-That hurt, right?
-Yes!
-Definitely not a dream.
-Yeah, it's not a dream. Not a
dream. Chris Pratt, everybody.
Chris and I are doing something
fun after the break.
Stick around.
Come right back. Don't leave.